Yelp is already counting down the 20 to
2023 by rating this year's top 50 places
to eat in Vegas yelp's Las Vegas
Community director Kayla Rambo is here
with Myra Arana co-owner of one of the
top spots LA paleta to ring in this
helpful list yeah I love it thank you
what is this here what is this sister
we'll get into what La paletta is doing
but first let's get into yelp's list how
was this list created what goes into it
what is it based on absolutely well
thank you so much for having us
um we're super excited to kind of talk
about our top 50 places to eat in Las
Vegas for 2022.
um the list really is data driven so
it's all the helpers out in the
community supporting these local
businesses and then from there we kind
of rank them based off of the data so
it's all the community going out and
supporting all these incredible local
businesses like La paleta is that that's
the number one most important part we're
supporting local businesses one of them
perhaps yeah you made the number two
spots it feels great honestly wow it's
an honor it's really an honor it really
is Yelp it's a big deal okay so let's
talk about back to what we were saying
let's talk about what you got on the
menu because this is colorful and
beautiful
thank you so much for having us so these
are all going to be our homemade this is
like our main okay explain what a
paletta is just in case
they're going to be all made out of
fruit or half fruit half cream and then
we have a bunch of homemade ice cream
this one's going to be my favorite this
is cheese so you're saying I have to try
it you have to try it you said it's
cheese you have to wait I have to fix it
up for you okay okay do your thing work
your magic is I like to put it start it
off with a little bit of queso fresco
and homemade uh Berry jam now you would
consider this a dessert yeah with cheese
on it guys
okay ready all right while I taste this
tell us about the other the other you
know places on the list and just you
know where can people find it absolutely
so there's so many different amazing
local eateries just like LA paleta on
this list
um we have Italian cuisine we have ice
cream shops we have vegan shops bakeries
there's just a ton of different local
lists for you to kind of check out
um and you can buy the list on our
Instagram at Yelp LV and we have the
full list there and then you can also
follow our Yelp collection in with our
top 50 places to eat so you can take the
list with you on the go in the Yelp app
thank you okay yeah of course
you can use delicious dessert tell
everybody where they can find you we're
gonna be in the intersection of Russell
and South Grand Canyon we are in 5651
South Grand Canyon Drive thank you so
much thank you cheers this is delicious
thank you so much